OVER.
SABRES FROM LEFT T
>>
SKATER.
STARTS ON THE LEFT ONE-TIMEME G.
A COUPLE TIMES ACROSS THAT THE .
NUMBER 38.
WITH A SHOT, REBOUND AND SCORE!
THERE.
>> Rob: TAKES IT INTO THE MIDDLE
OFO GO IN THE SECOND PERIOD.
BUFFALO WITH A 2-1 IN FRONT.
VICTOR OLOFSOURS AT
FITZGERALD.
NOW KREBS, THE FAR SIDE JUST
TOUCHED SHAW THERE A LITTLE BIT,
THE D ON THAT
ONE.
HERE'S A CHAILD PLAYER
STACKED UP THERE RIGHT IN A
WILD.
TO THE BLUE LINE, KAPRIZOV, SHOT
AND SCORES.
FOUR-MAN GROUP JUST A LITTLE OUT
OF SYNC CORNER,
JEFF SKINNER GETS ONE WHACK AT
IT ON THE BACKHAND AND THE
SKINNER, SKINNER, CHICKENUCK UP
AND SKINNER IS
CORNER.
SABRES DON'T GET IT UP BUT THE
NET IS UP THE MINUTE
IT'S A SABRES